let's go over to Zagreb with Maryse and
a special guest Maurice
well you asked for a yes sir and the man
himself is here Thomas laughs shortage
who is the Minister of Environmental
Protection and energy here in Croatia
and my colleague there - miss Lovett in
st. Louis he said why was this man
getting an applause nobody's gotten that
big applause so far what did you do to
make people such fans maybe they know
that I was for three months in st. Louis
in 2002 maybe that's the reason but I'm
not sure I don't know I thought that it
is let's say a usual thing that we just
play yourself as well tell us about your
young chess career I won't say that I'm
a chess player I would say that I used
to play chess once upon a time but
nowadays there's no enough time for that
but I like I like looking other people
playing chess from time to time and play
blades but that's from time to time I
have the fact that you said let's makes
us know you're a chess player and you
mentioned that you played the secondly
equation secondly yeah the date was in
1997 I think my last match in the second
league it was quite good and at that
time but since then no play you've had
some jobs you're gonna have to pull you
back into the chess world somehow
kicking on screaming tell us about your
job you've mentioned it's kind of a
conflict you've got environmental
protection on one side and then there's
energy on the other side to try to
combine them into one has been a
challenge for people all over the world
and it's your job to oversee that in
many countries these two things are less
Adriane separate ministries and in
Croatia we decided to take care all
together for for the energy and for the
environmental issues in in one ministry
and it's a it is always let's say a kind
of conflict between oil and gas and
environmental issues but I think that we
are going doing a good job in Croatia so
for us it's not a problem it sounds like
you'd be hated by two sides that's what
I'm hearing
yeah that's the position you know always
in the middle yeah there are too many
people who are unsatisfied all right
well this chess has been satisfying for
us seeing chess here in Croatia what
does it mean to see a world-class event
like this the best players on the planet
playing in your country I don't know
what does it mean for the others but I
can tell from my point of view the ten
minutes ago I played efore against
Magnus Carlsen so the best one in the
role in this moment I'm quite happy
because of the hats but to go from that
from the national point of view in this
moment in Croatia we have 12 players
which are in 20 as as far as I know in
the best 20 in the world first eight
players in the world are in Croatia and
the creation public is so interested in
this tour so I'm happy that we have them
here and I hope that the next year will
be the same that doesn't that's the idea
hopefully from our point of view all
right well you you're one of the bosses
make it happen and also the boss but
I'll do my best to do for you to come
next year to creation to be here maybe
to play one of the rounds in one of our
national parks or something like that
that'll be great the great ideas well
again you're one of the big dog big dog
so we're gonna hold you to it
tomislav shortage the Minister of
Environmental Protection and energy
there's so much support of the highest
levels here for chess in Croatia